[Music]
whether you're in it for the bottomless
mimosas the decadent pancakes or the
avocado toast brunch is hands-down the
best part of the weekend while enjoying
the finer things in life did you ever
stop to think about how this glorious
eating tradition began well it all
started with a man a man with a hangover
[Music]
back in 1895 there was this guy named
well guy and he was a writer living in
England at that time sundays were a big
deal an early post church meat heavy
meals were all the rage but for those
nursing a hangover and recovering from
the previous night's debauchery those
meals weren't always appetizing so guy
proposed a compromise and penned a
prolific essay appropriately named
brunch a plea he envisioned a hybrid
meal of sorts that was lighter than the
typical meat spread and included a
variety of pastries friends could gossip
about the previous night's indiscretions
while chasing their hangovers with some
hair of the dog
but the delicious British invention took
what seems like forever 30 years to
catch on in the States when it did
Sunday morning never looked the same
again so the next time you're enjoying a
french toast chased by a Bloody Mary
take a second to thank the hard drinking
Englishmen by the name of guide salty
sweet chewy crunchy it's a delicious
combination born from one of black
America's most consequential cultural
movements
[Music]
it was the 1930s the place was New York
City
it was the epicenter of black Americans
movement into mainstream culture the
Harlem Renaissance artists writers and
thinkers would gather at venues and
Harlem into the wee hours of the morning
listening to touring big bands and jazz
artists as the club stayed open later
and later
so did local restaurants to take in the
hungry concert goers one such restaurant
owner was Josie T Wells founder of well
supper club Wells became known for its
southern inspired menu but Wells needed
a hit to stay on top of the 2 a.m.
restaurant business what could he do
seeing an opportunity Wells realized
that the fried chicken leftovers from
dinner could be served with the freshly
prepared waffles for breakfast creating
a sweet and savory concoction unlike
anything else the dish was a hit
eventually word got out and chicken and
waffles became a soul food staple from
Atlanta to Los Angeles and though Wells
closed in 1982 the dish lives on so when
you think of the Harlem Renaissance take
Duke Ellington jazz clanks and Hughes
poetry and Joseph T Wells chicken and
waffles New York City the bagel capital
of the world
the place where bagels reign supreme in
our cut above the rest right
well maybe not because it turns out
there's something that could rock New
York and it's precious bagels to the
core Montreal has their own booming
bagel industry and there's a
constituency of big enthusiasts that
actually consider Montreal bagels better
than New York's shocking I know I lived
in New York for 50 years but I don't
care for the New York bagels and neither
does my family
Tiffani maybe go to New York really big
Olivia Maya what is going on here it's
time to investigate my name is Robert
morena and I'm the co-owner st. viateur
bagel shop people really know about us
and they know that if you come to
Montreal you gotta try Montreal bagel
every time I go to New York I always
visit a bagel bakery and I test my
bagels against theirs and I've yet to
come across something that compares to a
singular baby Montreal bagel is set
aside by its process of how it's made we
hand roll each bagel we boil it in honey
water we seed it and we bake it in a
wood-fired oven all right so Montreal's
got the sweet and doughy flavor what do
you gotta say about the New York
Montreal bagels yeah I think it's mostly
a fad honey water
who does that not good I'm speaking
about part sorry my name is Darren
Dolphy and I'm the operations manager
with HMH Midtown bagels East you want a
regular bagel you can go anywhere if you
want a true New York City staple become
the HMH Midtown bagel ceased look it's
New York City we're moving at a fast
pace we sell a lot of bagels some bagels
are made on machine others are hand
rolled like our cinnamon raisin big deal
scale same great taste it's a very labor
intensive process that takes roughly 24
hours from start to finish before we can
bake off the bigness so you each have
your own process big deal how do you eat
them so generally we do not cut our
bagels and they come out of a wood-fired
oven they don't need to be toasted
you've come you pick up the bagels and
they buy a cup of cream cheese and you
make the bagels yourself that's their
real montreal way of doing things got it
so in Montreal I have to make it myself
what about in New York when you walk
into H and H Midtown bagels East you
walk through the counter place your
order we slice the bagel we pop cream
cheese we put the LOX we wrap it up and
it's ready to go
New York started manufacturing bagels
before Montreal the big difference is
that we just kept our bagel making
traditions the same still horse and
wagon so if you're more of a sweet and
doughy do-it-yourself bagel maker montt
rails for you but if you prefer the
toasted bagel with everything on it you
got to come to New York but in the end
if there's one thing we can all agree on
it's that everything's better with cream
cheese this is coffee this is coffee
being poured into the most iconic Cup in
New York City history so how do they
sell over a billion of these
[Music]
this is Leslie buck a Holocaust survivor
immigrating to New York after World War
two he got a job working as a sales
manager at the sherry cup company the
company wanted to break into the New
York diner scene
Leslie notice Greeks ran most of the
diners so what did he do he decided to
create and design a cup that would
appeal to them
he used the colors of the Greek flag
blue and white along the top is a Greek
key one of the most iconic designs in
architecture
besides mimic a Grecian vase smack dab
in the middle Greek style lettering that
embodied the very soul and model of the
cup we are happy to serve you and guess
what it worked
Sola bought the sherry cup company in
1994 alone they sold over 500 million
cups and today the m4 cup has reached
full-blown icon status
nice work guys I have to have a pretty
girl if she's got no clothes on that's
even better I worked for Playboy I've
been doing that for 15 years but I was
the creator of the Cheerios B long long
ago I remember it as one of the earliest
things I did the bee that I drew I
thought it would be kind of fun to do
one that looked more like a bee so I
gave him big compound eyes and antennas
and that wasn't at all what they wanted
they thought he was a little too insect
like and insects and cereals probably
not a good combination but he eventually
ended up looking like he does now we put
shoes on which I didn't have in the
beginning when they gave him a sweater
so we was wearing something so it really
is more like a Disney character than
than an insect yes I always say looks
like Elmer Fudd in a bee suit the face
became more human he got a little nose
of course and eyes with pupils no
compound eyes why what is it with the
eyes well the eyes are the main thing
when you do a cartoon character you want
to a focus on the eyes after all and if
you can have eyebrows and eyes with
pupils you need something that can be
expressive
now you work for Playboy yes yes the
half said he liked my lady in the [ __ ]
eyes I try to keep things a little
innocent
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
nothing says britain more than nope nope
keep going oh yes there it is a nice cup
of tea
[Music]
we know we have China to thank for
introducing tea to the Western world but
how did it make its way to England and
become the cultural obsession that is
today well that's all thanks to one
Portuguese woman the year 1662
the person Catherine of Braganza she
just won the hand of England's King
Charles the second with the help of a
very large dowry including money
treasures and spices this worthwhile
trade made her the Queen of England
Scotland and Ireland when she arrived to
her new homeland she brought with her
packets of loose-leaf tea in crates
labelled transport Dervis aromatic us
it's a theory that this was later Berube
ated to te a t now t could all be found
in england but was only really used for
medicinal purposes catherine continued
drinking tea to her heart's content and
as the new royal everything about her
including her beverage habits was copied
by other ladies desperate to be just
like their idol another thing catherine
brought to the table from portugal was
the idea of tea drinking experience she
popularized the use of porcelain tea
cups and mugs but the end of the 17th
century much of British aristocracy were
enjoying the hot beverage and soon
enough so was everyone else today while
tea can be found pretty much everywhere
it remains a special daily pastime for
Brits hmm so carry on and drink tea
people of England
[Music]